hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course about somebody's own
speech in the symposium an impromptu
speech that he gave us having arrived as
a party crasher he decides that he's
going to praise Socrates rather than
praising long as all the other
participants have done and he's going to
recount a very interesting story of
seduction tale that we'll get to in a
minute I want to kind of situate that
within a larger problematic that has to
do with love and that centers around
Socrates himself
Socrates at least as Alcibiades portrays
him occupies a very strange you might
say unconventional position we've talked
quite a bit in many of the other videos
that have to do with a symposium about
the relationship between the lover and
the beloved in Greek the holidays and
they were old men Don and these were
distinctive roles the one who pursues in
the one who is pursued the one who he
has do you need to offer the one who
desires the beauty of the beloved and in
the case of Socrates a strange reversal
is going to take place Plato is telling
us about this and his place
in the mouth of alcibiades now the very
first thing that we see happening after
Alcibiades comes in drunk you know all
these garlands on him try to sit next to
Agathon is the best looking guy they're
the most attractive the most successful
it is you realizes that Socrates is
there and then Socrates says Agathon
it's your place you have to protect me
against Alcibiades and there's a little
bit of joking going on there but it's
also a little bit serious as well
Socrates said is that else of Mines
here's the the real upshot of this it
was a jealous not the jealous lover but
a jealous beloved so Socrates is the the
older person within the Dayan Socrates
is the one who presumably desires who
was infatuated with the others beauty
and charm and it's Alcibiades who
becomes jealous though Alcibiades wants
Socrates attention to be turned entirely
towards him not you know dispersed over
other beautiful in body and mind other
beautiful people so this is there's kind
of resistance there to the Platonic
notion that we saw in do Thomas speech
that you should move from just a single
infatuation with a beautiful body to
looking at many beautiful bodies and
seeing what's coming to them and loving
that attribute and then loving the
beautiful soul Alcibiades wants to have
Socrates entirely to himself
and so he is a jealous beloved rather
than a jealous lover what the des brings
us to though is that with Socrates
there's a weird shift that takes place
in the relationship and Alcibiades says
it's not just me it's also all these
other people like karma days and you
know this person in that person in this
person
and so we know that something like this
is the case that Socrates does in fact
spend a lot of time hanging out with the
good-looking the intelligent youth but
the question is what is he actually
after with it what is he trying to get
is Socrates kind of a dirty old man type
or is he attracted to the potential that
he sees in them and thinking about how
he might offer them the chance to become
better better young men and then better
you know mature men in the process and
what happens in each of these cases
Socrates is not a good-looking guy as we
talked about in the other video about
Socrates ugliness and beauty Socrates is
pretty ugly physically and sorry Jesus
doesn't have a lot of money he doesn't
have a social position he doesn't have
all these other things that people say
oh yeah that's it's really great to have
somebody desiring you like that
what does Socrates possess he at least
has a reputation you know he denies the
fact of this for possessing some kind of
wisdom and you know you can look at
other dialogues in which they they talk
about whether he is wise whether there
isn't wise Socrates himself has a whole
lot of explanations about this we don't
need to go into all of that at this
point suffice it to say there is
something enthralling about Socrates
himself
there is something attractive so
attractive that those who he is the
lover in relationship of role towards
the beloved end up becoming lovers
themselves totally appending things in
fact they end up being the ones to
pursue Socrates not Socrates the one to
pursue them
Socrates can sort of take it or leave it
and he'll be just fine and contend no
matter what they're the ones who become
enthralled with Socrates and chase after
him so it's it's an interesting kind of
like I said a reversal that takes place
Alcibiades
as in terms of a particular
characteristic he says that with
Socrates something happens it doesn't
happen with anybody else
remember Alcibiades is the golden boy of
Athens at the time he's good-looking he
is from a wealthy family that has great
family connections he is up to be you
know a military commander he's already
been given some military charges he's
charming he is the guy who has
everything sort of the Bruce Wayne but
with parents of the ancient world and
Alcibiades doesn't feel a sense of shame
or embarrassment or a sense of
impropriety in the face of anybody else
if somebody else criticizes him
Alcibiades has something to say he can
push it off he can he can find a way to
ignore it but if Socrates doesn't think
well of him it strikes at his very heart
and he worries because the things that
we're going to see this with the
seduction story the the currency that
Alcibiades has by which he can buy out
or by the favors of just about anybody
else that doesn't work with Socrates the
two things that work with Socrates our
intelligence and virtue and Alcibiades
as the person thinks about whether he is
living the proper kind of life he only
thinks this when he's with Socrates by
the way so when he's with Socrates he
feels a sense of shame he feels a sense
of not being everything that he could be
and so long as in the he's in the
presence of Socrates he's aware of his
own condition then he says when I when I
get out of Socrates is presence of
course then I just look at the public
and the mob and they tell me what a
swell guy I am and I start to believe
them and all that gets forgotten but
this is what I you know Alcibiades
giving speeches saying there's something
really special about this guy so now we
have what I really wanted to get to the
core of this of Alcibiades speech
he tells us something that is quite
shameful and so he's demonstrating the
fact that he does not feel a sense of
shame towards us towards the public only
with respect to Socrates and he's
already felt that shame with a Socrates
in this occasion so he's willing to tell
a story about how he the super
successful man was unsuccessful he's
willing to tell a story about how he did
something embarrassing and fatal in the
process so what does he tell us he tells
us how he tried to seduce Socrates why
would he want to seduce Socrates isn't
it the job of the logger to try to
seduce the beloved yes
but else of mine ADEs wants to speed up
the process because he figures there's
going to be a quid pro quo here he's
going to get some of Socrates wisdom
which he value is much more highly than
anything else and he figures well you
know if I have to be charming with them
or perhaps even have sex with him or you
know hang on his arm and be you know
what we call eye candy these days that
would all be great because I'm gonna get
something better out of it and I've got
plenty of this stuff over here I can
dole it out but Socrates can give me
something way better so if there's
anybody I'm gonna do this with it's
gonna be Socrates so he begins this
process by going to the park with his
his attendant and engages Socrates in
conversation and so they they're talking
back and forth of they're talking
philosophy as well as you know
pleasantries and stuff like that
Alcibiades sentences attendant away and
says all right now this is going to work
Socrates is going to put the moves on me
and turns out Socrates those who just
keeps on talking yes as normal she
doesn't pick up the hint as we would say
right or perhaps I just did pick up the
hint and he is not in the game for that
sort of purpose so I also find he says
all right that didn't work I'm gonna
have to get serious about this how can I
get this guy to deliver the goods to let
me deliver the goods so I can get the
goods
he wants he invites him to dinner now
this is something that the beloved
doesn't do this is something else uh by
today's comments on this he says I
treated him as if I was the lover and he
was the beloved I invited him to dinner
I'm now putting things out before him so
he invites him to dinner
and they have conversation that you
hadn't and house of mine he sends the
servants away and then Socrates as soon
as dinner is over he says all right it
takes off imagine he's got a bib or
something he says alright great meal see
you later and he ends up I hate these as
luck they're set you know what happened
the next time somebody says all right
I'm getting again it's almost like
watching Wile E Coyote trying to get the
roadrunner with this sort of thing isn't
it
Alcibiades make sure that this time the
dinners gonna go on extra milan socrates
is not going to be able to go home he's
gonna have to spend the night this is
how they're going to get together so you
know he has Socrates stayed the night
and it's cold so he creeps under
Socrates cloak you know what we wouldn't
know it's called a blanket or a
comforter and he tries to seduce
Socrates he tells him this was really a
great line socrates you're the only
truly worthy lover for me if I was going
to give it up to anybody you're the one
that I would do that for because you
actually have so much more to offer me
than all the other people who are after
me all the other people who would like
to get with me as we say and Socrates
does two things which actually does
three things that are they're worth
talking about one is he tells me how
somebody's you know we'll have to
consider whether that's a good idea at
some time not today but some other good
time so there's an infinite deferral
right and there's this this sort of
premise to that that unless it can be
argued that is a good thing for Socrates
he's not going to do it
so he's not just going to follow his
passions the way any normal person would
do
not because he doesn't have any emotions
or designers or anything like that but
because he understands the proper
relation of them so this is the second
point now Socrates is temperance he can
have a beautiful person laying down next
to him naked under the covers
singing basically I'll do anything you
want
and Socrates can say that's really not
what I'm about and that's not what I
want our relationship to be being
structured by and he can actually pull
it off he can not just say that sort of
thing
but follow throughout the entire night
so that's I so that the hell some IDs
can say when we got up the next morning
it was it was as if we were just
companions sleeping next to each other
and that lover in the lot the third
thing that's very important Socrates in
his response also says to Alcibiades you
know and really want to be careful with
this sort of thing you know if you if
what you're trading is sexual favors in
place of gaining wisdom you really would
be making out on the deal if I can
really give you wisdom that way you are
a smart guy but how do you know over you
who are not yet wise whether I do indeed
possess what you're looking for how do
you know you're not going to cheat
yourself and feel terrible terrible
about it
in the morning and you have regrets for
having given up something good for
something that is just valueless how do
you know that how societies so this is
the story that Alcibiades tells us about
this quite marvelous guy Socrates
instead of giving a speech in praise of
love he gives a speech in praise of the
object of love and he talks about this
guy who somehow transmuted the
relationship between beloved and Lara